the old wars cold war
war on terror he knew who we were
fighting
but now the enemy is invisible they can
destabilize entire countries from
simple reach of their keyboard
officially i can't put you on this but
if you were to go out on your own
i would need some help i'm guessing this
isn't a social pool i'm putting together
a team
and you're the best in the world of what
you do i thought this was done
i'll be back for dinner tomorrow
hands put your gun down please five four
three
two one pull the trigger or you can
listen
we all work for different intelligence
agencies
american british german colombian
chinese but now we have a common enemy
and if we don't stop them
they'll start world war three
so we need to join forces
you have cameras in your jewelry comes
in your earrings
this is like half the cia's most wanted
you bump i grab i like the new team
we'll take it from here
i've got four more agents out on the
street that guy was six
but thanks for the tip
i have two children i am a normal person
i cannot do this anymore bad guys are
out there right now
you go home you bring them with you
are you under control are you no
we put ourselves in danger
so others aren't
355.
you